you fool dude this part of this place is
going crazy
we lost Garrison Keillor and man went
down they get crazy kilo talking dude
slow talking public broadcast radio
could use your donations we love
bringing you quality content but it
comes at a price
yeah the first guy to go down was that
John Ghomeshi guy who is that Canada Oh
the CBC guy that was choking [ __ ]
oh who was the much he was like mr. calm
and God and progressive and I'm a
FEMINIST trust it I can call myself a
feminist ladies you listen you cannot
trust I'm not the best human being in
the world but I swear to God
what you see is what you get yeah all
right gotta be careful with these
[ __ ] male feminists that is just that
is a sneaky ploy to get [ __ ] what was
that one who was it was it Eric
Weinstein that was telling us about a
particular type of cuttlefish that
pretends to be a female so he can get in
close with the males and then because
the males don't recognize him as being a
threat what was it sneaky sneaker male
like a sneaker male Larry
yeah and they often operate like
underneath the large cuttlefish right
and with all the females yeah bangs um
you know the sneak tip that's the dude
that's like I understand you yes
sneaker male cuttlefish of Thailand
there it is yeah so it literally is like
a transgender cuttlefish it tends to be
a woman but really it's just trying to
get some [ __ ] that's it and its its
strategy is not to be the big you know
ever-present dominant male but instead
just slip around the girls
that's like girls that's like the one
straight dude
balle yeah he's like the women complain
to me about all the other guys and
didn't end up smashing them all like the
one straight dude in a church choir no
one you see those guys who they really
are when one of the ballerinas
boyfriends show up yes straight dudes
[ __ ] to them yeah you you've been
trying to know you've got this whole
thing cultivated you're watering it all
putting fertilize you set calendar
you got your fake books you're
pretending to read that you leave out
yeah yeah [ __ ] that we do everybody has
Garrison Keillor's he was he was
probably too you know just the intellect
man he was a professor he was the yeah
historial crush right Lake Wobegon he
created this whole world yeah it was
prince in mystic in garrison keillor
yeah so look at and look at that dude
dude was sling and dick oh I don't know
here's the thing though man all the
chick has to do is hate you
that's what scary yeah you're guilty
yeah it's the bucket is so wide it's
like it's the Weinstein of it all and
then it's I don't know yeah an hour of
it all I don't know what Matt did yeah I
don't know what he did either but then
there's like the louis c.k angle where
he doesn't even touch you he just jerks
off in front he like my boy Sato is that
you don't know what it's like to have a
dick like who would put everything in
peril scissors sir go off in front of
something like you know this is gonna
come back on yes so it has to be some
something which a dick that makes you go
I have to do this I think it's I've been
saying this for a while I think it's one
of the things that like makes people
funny too is that ridiculous way of you
in the world you're just chaotic
yeah impulsively you're nutty [ __ ] the
next thing you know you're like Kendrick
off in front of you like what you push
the limits let me see how ridiculous
people's lines
and it probably worked it might have
worked for somebody yeah that whip it
out like the whip in your dick out thing
like I know dudes that that was people
tried to get me to do that in Cana say
like yo you should just pull your dick
out I'm like that works yeah and I was
like I never had the courage to just
pull my dick out in front of a girls
we're doing all the time but when it
does work like holy [ __ ] I gotta figure
out what the rhythm is right there's
some times where it can't work and
you're like what how does that how's
that possible but then other times where
you'd pull your dick out girl be like
what the [ __ ] right like I'm sorry Jesus
you can't bat baseball averages with
your name alone game yeah that it's a
low I know average it's a low average
and those names back and hit that one
out of 100 today man coming out yes and
if you have like a freak girlfriend yeah
when you're in high school or something
like that and just ruins your perception
and you know what else [ __ ] it ought to
do is up the strip club they hang out
there so they have this false reality of
what you know oh yeah woman is this an N
when they go I'm just trying to talk to
a regular woman and like oh you gotta
get to know me first like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you just getting used to dealing with
freaks yeah you're dealing with freaks
all the time they have a different
different parameter not like the lady in
the office that handles accounting they
got on her no that is nice when you meet
a woman who has agency over her body and
knows what she likes that could [ __ ] you
up when you go and you didn't dealing
with somebody that's not that free yeah
yeah that could be that's a problem
we're we're girls just they're not
freeze the right word right there no
she's relaxed enough we're comfortable
enough in their own skin or you know
what they like and just can tell you and
like yeah yeah
yeah and that's when you have to decide
if you really like her because if you do
like focus on her and and bring that out
of her and you don't like her it's gonna
be hard yeah I dated a girl once a long
time ago
yeah way back in the day I was in my 20s
and I loved to having sex with her but I
hated hanging out when they said I know
man is that is that she how'd you how'd
you try to like ghost her when you were
she got mad at me he's one of getting
mad at me they just get mad at you yes
you're not doing what they want you to
do you're not marrying them you got this
you know